actually have a really awkward story
about when i set up the wi-fi here in
japan
um because um yeah obviously obviously
you know we just moved to japan
and one of the hardest things especially
when we moved here was
[ __ ] setting everything up initially
yeah jerry knows all too well
joey knows all too well kind of moved
here like two weeks before me so joe
can't have the cheat sheet or just
having joey set up everything for him i
was like i wanted to get in first with
joey i was like
i need help god's coming i know you're
gonna be sick of gone dude he like
perfectly planned out where i
would be burnt out right yeah because
like
i could see when you asked joey like to
help you set up i could see like
just the hope just wash over his face
and be like
oh this is the last time connor this is
the last time and
i remember when you were talking about
setting up like your driver's license
and
like i could see joey's just like no
don't ask me connor no i'm not i'm not
going to do it
i mean that i feel bad yeah luckily that
was someone else who i hadn't bothered
yet
so yeah so as i was setting up the
internet as as you know i have like
really really slow internet compared to
you guys
right um and i'm pissing a
peasant internet um i can't remember who
i'm with it's not a you
it's the other software
no it's not it doesn't matter but they
have to do something right yeah they
have like
english support which is why i picked
them right because i had to try and sort
this out by myself
um so when they said they have english
support
it's it's the most it's it's basically
just like here's the person who
translates using google translate
japanese companies are like english
support or for foreigners only
95 of the time it's just someone who
doesn't really speak good english and
just a way for them to hike up the price
oh yeah yeah like if you go to the like
uh like what is it like gaijin
is that what it's called yeah like that
that real estate website if you go and
find the same properties on a japanese
website they're much cheaper
yeah it's just like it's like thirty
percent cheaper everything it was just
like ah
it's like okay it's been taking
advantage of because uh you know
they do do that just ask someone who's
japanese to help you you'll save us your
time
you might lose a friend yeah at least
you'll have saved her just make a
japanese friend to eventually lose said
pay him the money that you saved
honestly there should be a service for
someone to help you because that would
have that that could save you a lot of
money out of service hire a japanese who
speaks english
to come with you
the reason i was able to set up my phone
was because luckily my cousin was here
at the time and i asked i asked her to
do it and she works
for jal so she can speak you know pretty
fluent japanese and she helped me set up
perfect no bumpy roads setting up the
internet what's up
[ __ ] nightmares i don't know i don't
know my phone so i'll tell mine after
yours okay
okay because like firstly you firstly
like you have to
sit up with the internet provider and
then also
set it up with something else as well um
i didn't have to do that for mine you
didn't you didn't have to do that
because
i i i've like i get billed from two
companies and i don't
exactly understand why it sounds like a
scam
no no no no it wasn't a scam i made sure
it wasn't a scam
because i no because i i i had this
english support
no no because because the google
translate are shortened
if you go off tech support they were
very nice they assured me
that my wife it was an indian guy on the
phone they they assured me
through google play cards you know it's
totally legit
[Music]
no but from what i understand you have
to set up with like the is the person
who provides the isp
and then i think and then the guy i
think because i think au provides both
services
whereas my my company did not provide
both services at once i think yours is
like
yahoo mobile or something right where
it's like it's probably like
it's probably like a version of like
yahoo or something like that because i
remember i had that and i
had to do something similar yeah because
the person that provides the line and
the person that like
installs the router and rents out the
router and stuff for you it's like two
separate
companies out there they're like [ __ ]
40 bucks yeah i know
no no but the thing is you can rent one
out and have them set
up for you or you can set up yourself
and so
i i chose no with the internet option i
had
i didn't even have that option because i
would have loved just to rent out router
and have the engineer
set up no i wasted a day trying to
figure out how to set up my [ __ ]
router
and you know connect it to the isp in
japanese and japanese menus and
everything it was it was a [ __ ] hell
but
before that i had to even just set up
the deal that i was getting right
and so i phone up and i'm just like okay
yeah i'm living here um
i ch i choose the english option and
even then
it's it's like it's rough it's it's a
[ __ ] rough kind of kind of like it
took me
i think an hour of an hour of an hour
phone call to communicate
10 minutes worth of stuff and just to
make sure that everything was correct
and i tell them all my details and so
we're going through it
and then they they tell me that we're
sorry
um this is the fastest internet you can
get at this house
uh at this apartment and i'm just like
that's like
your lowest option that you have on your
website because they have like they have
like different tiers
right they have they have like the high
paying option and have like the [ __ ]
peasant option
as they always do and they're like we're
sorry you can only get the peasant
option
and i was like asking why right and they
will say they told me
that um sorry your building is not new
enough
and it doesn't have the newest internet
installed yeah that's the problem with
japanese
internet is that like depending on the
building and the whys built into it yeah
they're just like we can't do it sorry
yeah
so ridiculous so i was like there's no
way that this is true because i my
apartment's
pretty modern it's it's it's like it's
it's i think it was
it's newer than mine it's newer than
your one and i i heard about the speech
you were getting so i was like
i was like i was like where's this
phantom speed going
yeah yeah yeah i was like doubts you're
stealing the the next door building
yeah yeah so so so like so like i'm just
like
let me consider this deal right so i am
so i hang up i phone up the next day
and so i could talk to someone different
right so i can just
make sure that uh it wasn't just that
it wasn't just that person i was
miscommunicating to right um
so i phone up i go through the same
[ __ ] hour phone call
without doing it again explaining yes
uh i just want to make sure that this
is the best option i can go for this is
the best option
and there isn't a higher option and and
the second person
i was talking to goes hold on a second
let me just talk to my manager
and so she gets her manager and uh her
manager comes on
it's the same [ __ ] guy i talked to
yesterday
and so i was just like yeah uh can i
just
make sure that this is the highest
option available
and he goes you're the guy that phoned
yesterday
aren't you and i was like yeah this is
this is this is awkward um can i just
double double make sure and he was like
yeah i mean i just
made sure again uh it's the best option
available and um
there's smaller phones i wonder if you
tried a different internet company yeah
i i wanted to and so i go i go through
the ordeal again and i you know
give them all my details again and this
time i actually have to send my
send my id or scan my id just to make
sure everything's all
everything's all kosher [ __ ] you're not
first bill i get
right i open up grant manny tapo
[Music]
i sent them my id so that they can
verify my name and address
and they and they [ __ ]
auto correct my name again
his name on the id must have been wrong
we're [ __ ] idiots in the uk
yeah i think the visa people just
spilled wrong [ __ ] the pizza people
[ __ ]
[ __ ] the girl what the [ __ ] a god
you just bought the shitty internet and
it's [ __ ] yeah i mean
i like so i bought the [ __ ] internet
turns out it was [ __ ] yeah
so yeah i mean i couldn't be bothered to
[ __ ] go through another like two hour
phone call with another company and
i just settled for it and uh i mean
trust me like even if you were perfect
in japanese it probably would have taken
just as long
like because my god